48 hours after they were shot dead in
their car whilst driving through the
West Bank Maya and Rina D two sisters
were laid to rest at a funeral in the
settlement of
their mother Lucy is still in hospital
fighting for her life
family are dual British Israeli
Nationals they lived in the UK before
moving to Israel
a rabbi who used to know them in North
London told us that they would hold
special prayers for the family tonight
they used to come to us at home from
time to time we knew them as a family
and they were just a delightful family
they were full of commitment Vigor
passion energy and they did wonderful
things for us whilst they were in the
community on Saturday night a number of
missiles were fired from Syria into
Northern Israel at least one also landed
in Jordan Israeli military blamed
iranian-backed militias and struck the
launch sites in retaliation
[Music]
uh Sunday at Al-Aqsa mosque was expected
to be a flash point but it passed
without incident
thousands of Jews prayed at a special
service at the adjoining Western Wall
and Jews again were allowed into tour
the Al-Aqsa compound
this time the police held back and it
seemed to work
the weekend has been more peaceful than
earlier in the week but the Jewish
holiday of Passover continues until
Wednesday evening and Ramadan has
another 12 days to run
and said Jerusalem in particular will
remain tense at least until then